your your your last five four or five
years we touched on that a little bit
but we're talking down below from rowdy
rich we're talking Russ
we're trippy even like the stuff you did
with six nine you know crazy right like
who is the the one artist that is a
new-school artist that you feel like you
have an insane chemistry with like that
it's just like Russ for sure I was gonna
say I got him not failed yet have we've
made I don't know we released how many
songs with him so far five five more
than that and Russ is the kind of guy
six or seven every time we would go in a
studio
we worked six or set whatever the number
of Records that's album is the number of
records we did y'all go out that's wild
and then like it's crazy cuz I I know
that like he kind of prides himself on
self production on but I remember seeing
an interview it was like oh the one guy
wanted to get in with what Scott Storch
yeah he was saying I think dr. Dre me
and Timbaland where his top three like
by getting like letting like letting
somebody like into this creative process
like it's got an honor man it felt good
like you know when people like you know
it gets you inspired when you feel you
know people are feeling what you're
doing and it's like because they don't
know what to expect after you know when
they're gonna come into the studio with
you like I remember Russ was even saying
he was like man it's one thing to get an
opportunity to come in and work with
Scott Storch but he's like and then for
it to be dope that's their that's that
that's the icing on the cake a hundred
percent ma'am